-I am very happy
to have you here.
You are one of those people
that have been in
so many iconic shows
I have loved over the years --
and films, as well.
However, Peter Gibbons
from "Office Space."
You are approached about this
character a great deal, I hear.
-That's probably the one, yeah,
that I get hit with the most.
-And people actually
have told you
that character
is inspiring to them.
-Yeah. I mean, people will
come up to me from time to time
and say, you know, "This movie
and you were the reason that I
quit my job and walked away
from my livelihood."
-Wow.
-And I'm always a little --
I wait five seconds before
I say, "Good for you,"
'cause I don't know
which way it went.
And then, yeah,
it's usually good or they
wouldn't they'd have just
taken me out from behind.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-And then, so, you're also
on "Sex and the City."
-Yes.
-You were Berger.
-Yes, I was Berger.
-And you had one of the great
somebody recognized
you as Berger of all time.
I feel like being in that show,
having a part in that show,
explain who recognized you
at a Lakers game.
-It was so surreal.
The agency I was with
at the time
had courtside Laker tickets.
And, for some reason, everyone
else must have been out of town,
'cause I got the invite to go.
And, at some point during
the second quarter,
there was a ball out of bounds,
and Kobe came over
on the in-bound.
And he looked at me and did a
double take and said, "Berger?"
I was like, "Wow!"
-That's really great.
-Yeah. I'll always have that.
-You'll always have that.
I was mentioning
to you, backstage,
I've never seen the show.
My wife's making me watch it.
I'm enjoying it a great deal.
I haven't come to Berger yet.
-I won't spoil it.
-Okay, great.
Will I --
After I see the Berger arc,
will I think, "Man, Carrie --
I wish Carrie had
ended up with Berger"?
-Only if you have a really
messed-up idea of relationships.
-Okay, gotcha. Well, we'll see.
We'll see when
that moment comes.
You have a 5-year-old, yes?
-I do.
I have a 5-year-old and a
2-year-old, who's about to be 3.
-And you are -- you're raising
them in L.A., obviously.
-Yes.
-How is --
Obviously, you have a new show.
You have billboards.
Your face is on while
they're driving down the street.
How is that for them?
-It's kind of -- Well, first of
all, I think kids today --
it's not quite so weird
to see people on TV,
'cause they see
themselves on TV.
Everybody can,
you know, shoot everything.
But the billboards are
a little bit different.
And, you know, the kids
kind of respond to it.
But it is L.A.,
so, you know, a couple of
the other preschool dads
were saying,
"Yeah, my kid came and said,
'Daddy, when are
you going to be on a billboard?
I've seen three of them already
of other parents
in the school.'"
-That is, yeah,
raising a very unfair bar.
-Yeah, it's
great values, great values.
-So, this new show -- I don't
want to give too much away,
but this is something
that has been in
the trailers and
the promotion of the show.
Your character commits suicide.
-Yes.
-And this is -- You are still in
the show, from flashbacks.
-Yes.
-What made you choose
to do a show
where your character so
immediately dies?
-Well, my first thought was,
"I'm old enough to remember
'The Big Chill.'"
And I thought, "It worked out
for Kevin Costner."
-Yeah.
-Right?
-Jackpot for Costner.
-Yeah.
And he didn't even say anything.
-Yeah. He was, like, in and out.
-Yeah, right?
-He had like two days work.
-Now he's dancing with wolves.
So I felt pretty good about it.
It's also --
I'm doing another show,
on Audience network,
called "Loudermilk."
It's Season 2 of doing that.
That's kind of my day gig.
-Uh-huh.
-So, this one -- it sort of had
to be a limited thing
or it just wouldn't have been
able to happen.
-Gotcha.
-So it was great.
-Are you in --
How far into the process of
Season 2 are you
on "Loudermilk" now?
-I think "Loudermilk" --
we've shot all 10 of them.
And "A Million Little Things,"
we're up to,
I think, 106 or 107.
-And "Loudermilk" is --
For who don't know,
this is another
sort of complicated character.
Explain that character
a little bit.
And what made you
want to do that one?
-He's basically the
biggest A-hole in the world.
-Uh-huh.
-I can say that, yeah.
-Yeah, you can say that.
-Okay.
-You could say
the whole word, if you want.
Go for it.
Try it. See how it feels.
-No, no. I'm not gonna do it.
-Okay.
-I don't want the fine.
-That shows how different
you are than "Loudermilk"
that you won't even say it.
-That's right.
-Yeah.
-And, you know,
he's sort of, like,
this deadbeat,
you know, misanthrope,
who's a recovery counselor,
a substance-abuse recovery
counselor
for this group of
misfits and numbskulls.
And it's just classic,
you know, comedy.
It's the Farrelly brothers.
Will Sasso is on it.
It's a blast to do.
-And you -- Obviously,
you're working with
great television-makers,
great filmmakers.
Matt Weiner -- "Mad Men" --
has a new show called
"The Romanoffs."
-Yes.
-You're in that, as well.
-That is a show --
very inscrutable trailer.
Very hard to tell
what the show is about.
-Yeah.
-Can you understand
what it's about?
-No. I was in it and I have
no idea what it was about.
I don't know.
-You're confident we'll
all like it?
-I am.
I think because Matt's
a mad genius,
but he is one of those guys
that just likes everything
to be secret so that it can,
you know, do the whole thing.
And I respect that.
It's an anthology -- Well,
I don't know.
I think it's an --
All I know is --
I'm in only in one of them,
so I assume -- I hope everyone
else is not in all of them,
and I'm the only --
I don't know.
-Oh, yeah.
My fingers are crossed
that you find out.
"No, everybody but Ron's
in all of them."
-Oh.
I'll be like, "Oh, gosh."
I looked really dumb on
"Seth Meyers."
-You're not from Chicago,
but you lived
there after college?
-Yes.
-And what brought you to
Chicago in the first place?
-You know what?
It was just one of those things
where I got out of school
and I was kind of
floating around.
And I knew I was going to give
acting a shot somewhere.
I was probably too chicken
to come and try it in New York.
I thought about Seattle
for a minute,
because I didn't really know
the difference between
acting and music.
And then sort of
decided on Chicago
because it was close to home
and Steppenwolf was a big deal.
-Sure.
-You know, had been a big deal.
So we were all chasing that.
-The first time I saw you
was in "Swingers."
Did you meet those guys
in Chicago?
Did you meet Favreau there?
-I met Jon in Chicago
and I met Vince --
Jon and I moved to L.A.
at about the same time
and became closer friends
sort of by the fact that
we were the only two people that
moved to L.A. in that month,
and so we only knew each other.
But he knew Vince from doing
"Rudy" earlier, the two of them.
And they -- I mean, it's kind of
a documentary, "Swingers,"
really, of what it was like
to be 26 in L.A.,
starting out as an actor.
-I mean, you know,
obviously, one of the legend
of that movie is,
you know, you guys couldn't
possibly have known
you were making this film
that was going to,
again, like, sort of
be this indelible mark on
that moment in time,
which it certainly is.
Did you have any sense that
it was going to be
a film that people were gong to
see and remember for this long?
-No. We didn't think
it was going to be
a movie that we were in.
We rehearsed --
We did readings of it
for like a year,
trying to help Jon sell it,
with the idea that, "Well,
we're never going to be in it,
but maybe some producer
will see us," you know?
-Right.
-And then it just worked out
that we got to do it.
And it's, you know, lightning in
a bottle, one of those.
-Yeah. A fantastic film.
And I was living
in Chicago at the time,
and it was so cool to us that
like, "Oh, my God.
Those guys who lived here
went to L.A. and made a movie,
and now everybody's
talking about it and stuff."
-Right.
"What are we doing in Chicago?"
-Yeah. "We've got to get to L.A.
and do one of those
producer tables."